this is a production of cornell
university
today i'd like to present to you
adventures in
plant exploration plant diversity
and i've inverted it a little bit marvin
i hope you'll give me
the rights to do that plant diversity
from the other side of the world
to my back door
i'm going to start by giving you an
introduction to the u.s department of
agriculture national clonal germplasm
repository
then i will describe several of my plant
collecting
expeditions which have culminated in my
third
item the description of a newly named
decaploid strawberry from oregon
high cascades
this is a map of western oregon as you
can see many native peoples inhabit this
region prior to settlers from the east
the red dot in the center delineates the
location of our gene bank
you can see that our federal facility
lies in the middle
of land where the caliph peoples fished
hunted
and gathered abundant wildlife
for their sus sustenance
they seeded their lands to the u.s
government through several
treaties in 1854 and 55.
they gave us the word willamette where
the river
ripples and runs fast
you in geneva new york have a clonal
gene bank that preserves
apples cherries and now hemp
our gene bank is in corvallis shown at
the arrow
we also have temperate fruit nut
specialty crop resources conserved at
our facilities
which includes a main building
laboratories
60 acres of field collections
greenhouses greenhouses
and additional shade structures
our assigned crops include hazelnuts
strawberries hops
mint pear
currants and gooseberries blueberries
and cranberries
and cropwild relatives that are
cross-compatible
or graft-compatible with those other
crops
the germplasm of our crops serve a total
annual farm gate value
of about 6 billion dollars
we have 10 permanent staff members
they have been essential employees
maintaining
our genetic resources and performing
evaluations and characterizations
of our accessions throughout the
pandemic in addition we have
temp uh seasonal helpers
and students undergraduate and graduate
students
we have three scientists and seven
technical positions at our gene bank
we're in the process of recruiting for
our tree fruit curator position
to replace joseph postman who was our
pair curator but recently retired
the gene bank objectives are to acquire
maintain distribute evaluate and
document
plant materials assigned to our
gene bank and plant exploration
is a large portion of the acquisition
so why explore for plants well my
feeling is it's in human nature
throughout history plant exploration
trips have
been documented queen hashishput's
fleet landed in punt
on the northeastern coast of africa with
exotic merchandise for egypt back in
1500 bce
early botanical collections of strange
plants and seeds
were brought back from syria how do we
know this
the images in the upper left-hand corner
were
carved in the walls of the temple of
karnak
egypt and that carving dates to 1450
bce we're going to skip over the history
to the 1890s the turn of the century
1900s
nikolai ivanovich vavilav a brilliant
russian botanist and phyto-geographer
was a global thinker because of his
difficult
childhood growing up with famine he
focused his efforts and great energy
towards improving the human condition
he wanted to find a way to feed the
russian people
but vilov's genius began with the
concept of plant variability as
described by
darwin and others he took the idea a
step further
and from the tip of his pen realized
that our major food crops which were
developed over millennia
must have originated from a central
point
from which they successfully dispersed
he hypothesized that these as he called
them centers of origin
were likely where the genetic diversity
of the crop species is high
but vilov began to painstakingly
search for those centers through plant
exploration
and evaluation over the short course of
his career he participated in
eight expeditions from 1913 to 1933.
his ideas triggered staff such as the
david fairchild of the u.s department of
agriculture
to realize how important plant
exploration
is for the diversification of gene pools
for plant breeding and the development
of improved crops
i am just one of a long line of usda
staff members who have had the privilege
to be assigned to participate on plant
collecting expeditions
a number of the usda plant explorers
were quite successful
i encourage you to read the world was my
garden
a book by david fairchild unfortunately
for some explorers
such as frank n myers although he spent
nine highly successful years collecting
for the u.s department of agriculture in
china
he died by drowning in the yangtze river
near shanghai in 1918.
my expeditions were not fraught with too
many difficulties
other than being saved by a gps
when lost in the chahote allen mountains
near downey gorsk
or accidentally going into the men's
bathroom
in toyama japan as a result of my
incorrectly reading the hiragana sign
or having been discovered by bears as we
hike down the copper river trail in
cordova alaska
or avoiding the four species of
toxicodendron in hokkaido
not to mention avoiding [ __ ] and fire
ant bites
on the ankles in southeastern u.s
or the mosquitoes and gnosiums in new
england
i could easily speak for an hour on each
of these expeditions
but today i will give you a few excerpts
about some of them the ones
highlighted in yellow i expect
um it will be the ones that i talk about
and i expect that you might want me to
present
the more movie version of my expeditions
and i really did not coordinate this
at all with marvin pritz i think we are
just
thinking alike uh so i hammed up my
presentation
on my first expedition our trip to the
russian far
east in 2001. vladivostok
is the prince of the east city and
russia
and i'm going to be talking about
indiana and the siberian safari
the expedition was funded by usda
plant exploration grant
my mouse working yes we are co-starring
the american cast and marvin you can
start singing the indiana theme song at
the moment
we have indiana nick forsa
and kim hummer for the american cast
nick forsa is the geneticist from
rutgers university
uh he specializes in cranberries and
blueberries
and he speaks russian uh he accompanied
me
from the united states and
co-starring the russian cast
we have dr andre sabatov who is a
geneticist
and scientist senior scientist at the
vavilav research institute
in vladivostok his wife arina
vedinskaya pavel cherbuken
who is now the director of the far east
experiment station
then he was most interested in
collecting
actinidia and schizandra vines
and he promised me that i needn't worry
about
the tigers he would make sure that none
of them
harmed us on our trip
the veer station in saint petersburg
sent a scientist to accompany us on the
trip
as well this was vera fintova
her expertise was in grasses and
agronomy
and so nick and i referred to her as
vera the spy
but really she was quite wonderful to
work with our driver was nikolai
ilenko and our truck
our transportation was played by
a military troop transport vehicle
four-wheel drive
we had a plywood floor so that the place
where the troops would put their feet
became the storage hole for the camping
gear and luggage
five of us either sat in the back with
our legs extended while andre sat up
front with the driver
and most of the roads were not paved
the climate of the region
the day before we got there a huge
monsoon came through
we tried to arrive in a r
rough ride on the airplane flying in
from
seoul south korea the plane had to
turn around and go back to korea we
didn't know why at the time
but the airport runway was under several
feet of water
so we spent an extra day in seoul
went back the next day the water
subsided and we landed safely
the flooding though was still occurring
in the rest of
the area that we were collecting we
started out by plan
planning at the ni vilov all
russian research institute the veer
station as it's called
in vladivostok and in those days
we had to use topological maps there
were no google maps to
go on and we were planning our route
our expedition as i mentioned occurred
in this truck
and it's really interesting to try to
translate the cyrillic
these are v's that n
is an i and the p is an r so v
i r that's the vilav research institute
symbol
our route included going north of the
usury river
cutting in across the
alina uh mountains to
downey gorsk traveling up the coast
for the sea of oh hosts and then
heading back west to
havarov's city and then we returned
down to vladivostok
following the usury river
we collected a lot of small fruits
including black currants
and blueberries i was interested in the
black currants
because the white pine blister rust is
native
in this region and i hope to find
uh what was at one point called ribes
usuriensis
uh which was selected for
the gene for resistance to rust so we
collected
several different types of black
currants
uh we had from the boggy areas
vaccinium eulegonosum a relative of
blueberry
coralis manchurica was overhead along
with pirace usuriensis named after the
usury river and we collected
cranberries and cranberries for
nick forza there were several different
variants
in polyploidy in addition we collected
hop from one of the
nearby one of the cities and rubus
morris another bog plant
all in all we spent 21 days plant
collecting
we had 111 samples collected
22 genera 32 species
and this is a photo of us at three in
the morning before we were to take off
the next day
we had to package up everything and get
it ready for
plant inspection so we could take off
from the airport on time
and i have to say that pavel was true to
his word
he kept the tigers away we saw nary a
one
my next plant collecting expedition that
i'll talk about was hokkaido
three years later in july of 2004
the colleagues that i went collecting
with dr tom davis from the university of
new hampshire
dr hiroyuki iketani from
the scuba city hiroyuki
emenishi from akitai university
and you can see that hokkaido is not
too far it's a couple hundred miles from
the russian mainland where we were
in 2001 but the flora
is quite different and our traveling
mode was quite different as well
we were a little more modernized taking
a
a car and we even had navigation
opportunities in the car which was quite
a step
up our primary collection
focus was to obtain a wide sampling of
forgeria enume
as pictured here in the lower right this
species is a significant contributor to
the octopoid genome
as recent geo genomic studies have
determined
this species is distributed on the
western side
of hokkaido plant collecting couldn't
have been easier
we drove down this road
opened the door and before you even got
out of the car
you could pick strawberries
of our target species
besides the fregaria enumei we were also
looking for cropwild relatives of
blueberries
this is an example of vaccinium hurtum
you can see it has a polygonal shape
if you look in cross section
as opposed to another species vaccinium
smaller eye that was
uh cohabiting the same space
small eye has a globose fruit
so you could tell them apart by that
distinction
and the red foliage was approaching
the fall so in summary in hokkaido
we circumnavigated the island
spending 21 days we collected a hundred
samples of nine genera and 29
species
jumping over to florida in 2006
two years later for the florida
expedition
i was accompanied by dr paul lyrine
he is a geneticist and breeder from the
university of florida
he is responsible for having bred
load chilling and no chilling blueberry
varieties
into hybrid blueberries
and his breeding was a game changer
the whole blueberry production scheme
changed
to being able to produce what was
a northern adapted plant
into southern regions on this
florida collecting trip we collected
many
diploid species such as eliadii
vaccinium daroi that's the low-growing
plant in front of me
and vaccinium fuscatum you can see it
becomes
an older plant it gets to a height of
several meters tall
but the fruits are a little bit
different than our
vaccinium corymbosum of our cultivated
blueberry
but this is a diploid form of vaccinium
core ambosem
in addition to these diploid species
there were tetraploids
in um florida as well
this is a map from sam van der kloot in
his book
a monograph on vaccinium of north
america
in 1988 and i realized
by looking at the map that we had been
collecting
at the most southern point of vaccinium
core ambosem
uh and a mere 10 years later i was
able to go to quebec with michael
dossett
and collect vaccinium cormbosum
from this highest
latitude location of vaccinium core
ambosem as well
so i've spanned the range of cormboson
and also
collecting in the middle
for florida we collected 66
samples of three genera nine species and
four
intergenetic uh um interspecific
hybrids uh and the low chilling
vaccinium species are so
important to blueberry production today
it has changed the way we are able to
have blueberries
we can have blueberries throughout the
year any time of the year you can go to
the grocery store and get blueberries
because of these
low chilling types that have been
marketed
towards northern markets these
blueberries
grow in southern california portugal
spain
now mexico and most recently peru
are producing blueberries and selling
them
in northern markets it has enabled
the um people that haven't had
money to become
be able to produce agricultural crops
of great use and in this collection it
was very important for paul
irene who mentioned to me how
endangered these small patches
of pine barrens are that are
small in size but they're 10 miles from
disney world
because the need for development of the
land
the cement that is being put down the
houses that are being there
they are challenging these small areas
of native wild materials so
by bulking these seeds and bringing them
in an exit to situation we
have conserved their genes
next i'm going to jump into vietnam
in 2015 i had the great opportunity
to travel to vietnam with my colleague
jim oliphant
who is our greenhouse manager here and
he
is a vaccinium expert
and also we worked with the plant
resources center of the vietnam academy
of agricultural sciences
uh trans t2 hawaii
is the assistant director
of that plant resources center
and win von ken
who we called ken also
accompanied us on that trip
why vietnam northern vietnam
is the southern edge of the himalayas
there
are many mix of human
races and plants in that area
it's the 16th most biologically diverse
country in the world
there's more than 12 000 native plant
species
some of them are yet to be described and
there's 1500 edible fruit
and vegetable species located there
the highest endemism is concentrated in
the
hong leonsan mountains that's where we
were in the northern part of vietnam
um we didn't get to see the human fort
forests of central vietnam however
there were 36 species of rubus in hong
leon song
we visited four different
national parks and nature reserves
including tamdow national park
the hong leon song national park
we also went to fiac fia den
mountains in cowbang and we finished up
in babe lake
you know here in oregon we have a field
bindweed
that is called con convolvulus
arvensis and it is a naturalized from
asia and it's a noxious weed and so we
think of it
well somewhere over the rainbow in
asia we realize we're not in oregon
anymore when the noxious weed is
heavenly blue morning glory
it's ipomnia tri-color
which is from south america so
asia sends us its weeds and the americas
and other weeds to other parts of the
country
i found that enlightening so this was an
introduced and naturalized
weed the seeds however of this one
contain lysergic acid amide
not the diethyl form anyway interesting
side
branch there we have
in vietnam excuse me one second
there are so many different types of
rubus i was
overwhelmed rumi's sumatranus
is a raspberry type the fruit
dehiscence from the taurus and it forms
sort of a globe
unless it collapses uh and
it can be distinguished by the red hairs
besides the nodal prickles that it has
on the stem
and for each of these trips we prepare
voucher specimens
besides collecting wild materials
and for voucher specimens we have
presses
and not only do we collect terrestrial
plants
but sometimes we need a mountain elf to
climb up
an oak tree to reach the epiphytic type
plants that are above
our heads and so jim oliphant was our
mountain elf
an expert tree climber to obtain
some of these high located germplasm
vaccinium relatives
another type of rubus rubus reflexus
uh we had four different varieties
botanical varieties that were present in
vietnam where we were and i'll just
show you a close-up of one of the
stipules
uh it's a way that rubus uh can be
uh separated from other species
fancy pan as i mentioned is the highest
in indochina
and it's uh was a long climb
uh there's a hut um actually
about a third of the way up there's a
second hut
another third of the way up before you
hike up
to the very top and around
the halfway point at this hut where we
spent the night
there are many rubus species
this particular one is rubis
glabrocarpus
and this hawaii was just taking a photo
of this very interesting tri-lobal
rubus species jim
and ken and also several
of our sherpas we did have sherpas going
up this mountain who
carried our food for us
they hiked up the whole summit
to 3000 meters and a group of us stayed
back
and collected rubus from the middle but
since they hiked up this the whole way
they received some medals for their hike
which was a a lovely thing
and at the summit they found vaccinium
malpenensis
a vaccinium hep he bi which is
only found on the summit and in addition
this rubus idiofolius it's an endemic
found only at the top of fancy pan
so by the end of the trip we had
blueberry wild relatives like vaccinium
gulf therifolium
guaca rubrum and we had
fragaria neil dirensis
many many rubus because that's a center
of diversity for rubus a total of 95
accessions
and 48 species including dossinia
a relative of apple
we traveled up hiked up this
path but we found out
that the fancy pan cable car opened
february 2016. we had been there
in october and november of 2015.
so this happened after we were there
and there's a thousand room hotel at the
bottom of the gondola
so i have a feeling that oz is no longer
oz
here and i worry for those
two or three native species that are
only found
at the top of fancy pan mountain
well i'm going to bring it home with my
plant collecting
in oregon which has occurred over a
number of years
but strawberries have been a great
interest for me
and i
show you the distribution of fragaria
platypetilla
which is an octoploid and its
distribution
in oregon looks about like this
sever several years ago we began
looking taking a closer look at
platypetala
the red dots represent specimens of
platypetal
that have been deposited at the
herbarium at oregon state university
i've examined each of these specimens
and i've hiked
up and down the river ranges
for the cascade mountains and the
coastal range
and i've hiked in the eastern part of
oregon
to examine and collect samples
hancock at all in 2004 did a study
defining a super core of octoploid
germplasm
and one of the samples that they had for
garia 110
was collected by our first curator
autogen
in 1982. he hiked along the pacific
crest trail
which runs in the middle of the cascades
but the more we looked at 110
the more it became more unusual
about that time preeta
nathawet a thai graduate student
and professor yanagi
from kagawa university became
interested in doing a project with me
looking at
ploidies in strawberry we realized that
this fragaria itrupensis that was
collected from itroop island which is
two islands north of hokkaido
was a decapoid and when
dr nahla basil and her graduate student
wambui nuguna
examined ssr markers of
our fragaria looking at
what we thought were octoploid
chilawensis and virginiana types
the fregaria 110 again we thought it was
octoploid
at first but it was grouping with
fergaria it
pencils which is a decapoid so we knew
something was unusual
so i wanted to find out uh and then when
preeta did
some uh chromosome counts he also
counted 70 chromosomes on that sample
from 110.
so i went to burnt lake pacific crest
trail
echo mountain big lake all these places
up and down the oregon cascade mountains
and samples from this region in the high
peak cascade region of oregon
these samples were all decapoids they
had 10 sets of chromosomes instead of
the usual
eight whereas when i went hiking
in western oregon and eastern oregon
i went up to washington state
and california looking at collections
that other people had made these samples
were octopoids
and that was what everybody thought that
there were only octopoids out there
but right in this corridor of the high
peaks
there were decapoid strawberries
so i went to my colleague aaron liston
and said what do i need to do to name a
new species
he said you have to have differentials
kim
so i began looking at what makes this
species
different than the other octopoid types
if you look at the leaf closely you'll
see
hairs one millimeter two meter long
hairs
and that is unusual because in
platypetala the octopoid
there are no hairs on the top side of
the leaf
the fruit inflorescence had a range of
sizes
sometimes it was small
the way it is in fragaria bractiada
and sometimes it's tall uh
and so
there were different types of
descriptors that i could use
to categorize this plant so
the octopoid for gary of virginia
platypedilla
did not have hairs whereas
on cascadensis there were these one to
two milli
millimeter hairs on the top side of the
leaf
the seeds of cascadensis were comma
shaped
and not the usual straight edge
from the stipular end of the
aquine and they were a little bit more
like
frageria vesca which is a diploid but
this one is octopoid this one is
decapoid and this
is the octopoid so you can see a
difference in the speed
more seed morphology the habitat as i
mentioned
is in the high oregon cascades
beautiful place they had they'd chosen
a very lovely place to be growing
and um i was able then
to name a new species in 2012.
so getting to the end of the talk here
i've participated in more than 18
planned collecting expeditions i've
contributed
1323 i looked them up
accessions to the gene bank in
the u.s national plant germplasm system
and i have a link here where one can
see go to that link and see the
different accessions that i have
contributed to the
grin system i was able to name fragaria
cascadensis
from my backyard in the cascades
in 2012 and we're working on
some new reports of species extensions
for the range of six species in vietnam
i want to thank my many mentors
including
jim balington geneticist and breeder
from north carolina state university
he collected with us in
virginia and west virginia i didn't get
to tell you about that trip
dr henrietta chambers my mentor
she uh is an emeritus professor from
oregon state university
and people like francis lawrence maxine
thompson
and melvin westwood all
guided me in taking up plant expeditions
and collecting karen williams is a
botanist
at the plant exploration and exchange
office in beltsville
she helped arrange for the um
agreements that had to be put in place
for plant collecting expeditions gary
kynard the research leader
in my many collaborators who accompanied
me on all of my expeditions and
that would include the foreign and
domestic people
so i uh really appreciate their help
in setting me on my way and i thank you
guys for
asking me to give this presentation
because it
got me to pull together some of the
exciting
trips that i've made over my career so
i'm going to stop sharing my screen
and i hope that i've left a little bit
of
time for questions
absolutely fascinating presentation kim
i feel like you could have gone
on for hours and we would still
have been fascinated so thank you so
much for that uh not a question i just
wanted to
mention um you spoke about david
fairchild
earlier and um i really enjoyed
a book written about him called the food
explorer
so i want to recommend that and very
recently
read a pretty new book
uh called the wardian case all about
how the wardian case has been important
for plant exploration uh particularly
in the 19th century but with that let me
open things up to questions from others
kim uh really enjoyed your presentation
uh what a fascinating story just to be
curious about the
new strawberry species you named uh
it's named based on cascade mountains
right so yes
from the cascades yes as the leaves of
the new species have
um you know one to two millimeter hairs
there
do you think this species is more
drought tolerant
or cold tolerant
generally you know having more hairs can
prevent water loss
did anyone look into that i
we have not looked into that just yet
uh there are uh
it grows in the high cascades so
it is subject to snow and cold but then
it constantly gets snow protection so
it's somewhat removed
from the very coldest of days in the
mountains because of the
the snow cover the hairs are
interesting there are actually
well we use that to separate out between
platy petala
and uh cascadensis
um and and i should say prageria
virginiana subspecies plotted petaluv
which is the octopoid form
and fragaria cascadensis in oregon
the hairy tops of the leaves you can use
that as a distinguishing character
when you get to
washington cascade mountains
say you go to snoqualmie pass which is
to the east of seattle there they have
strawberries growing up in the top of
their mountains but that is
bulgaria virginia platypetala
but sometimes it does have hairs on the
top side of its leaf
there but they are all octopoid
so uh there but um maybe
hairs do help with cold because
uh in some of the northern part
of the washington cascades they do have
hairs on
on their plants there too thank you kim
when i uh
go back to uh corvallis next time i'll
make sure to
stop by and look at that species oh i
would be glad to
show you them yes and right behind me is
mount washington
which is where i was collecting the
fregaria cascadensis so that's my
background
thank you kim
kim could you check a question in the
chat
uh sure
okay um
okay let me get down from uh
is is the new strawberry species used
traditionally
uh as ntfp
i'm not quite certain what nt fp would
be
however
i i haven't seen specific
reference to this species over other
strawberry species
i do know that oh non-timber forest
product um
i guess i don't know exactly the
qualification for a non-timber forest
product um you know
native peoples would have gathered all
berry crops
whatever type species that were there so
i'm sure
you know that uh uh the
endemic peoples would have used this
berry as much as the one
in the lowlands um
it is not one that is commercially
um cultivated it
has a small berry as perhaps you might
remember from the image that i showed
it's about the size of your
thumbnail or little finger
nail so uh and the fruit
is not sweet the way an alpine berry
fruit is um but
it it could be a mechanism for
transferring
the deccaploids do offer a way of
transferring genes from a diploid
setting into an octopoid setting so some
of the breeders are looking for it for
other applications
i think we have time for one more
question if
someone composed that
you might have a question so we started
off uh both our seminar
and your talk with a land
acknowledgement so i wonder if you could
say a few words about
what sort of arrangements you make when
you go into another country and
you know use their germplasm and our
breeding programs what
sort of reciprocal arrangements or can
you say about it's probably different
for each country but
can you sort of tell us what your
guiding philosophy is on that
i chose to speak about my expeditions
this time because i only had limited
amount of time
i would love to come back and talk about
the particular regulations
involving plant expeditions because i'd
like to
inspire people to collect plants but we
now have
the international treaty on plant
genetic resources for food and
agriculture
which requires that we set up mutual
benefit
anytime we collect with another country
we realize that germplasm is the
sovereign property
of the location in which it's growing
we need to make uh rep reparations or
agreements with the um
the country of the region uh so that we
can collect the materials so
now when we collect materials uh after
2004 of july
after the hokkaido trip that i took in
2004
anything from then on collecting in a
foreign land
we have to have material usually the
plant materials are transferred
according to the it
this international treaty which provided
for
the standard material transfer agreement
smta and uh
so that is the permissions for
collecting
and provides for recognition of
the originating country from which the
germplasm
has emanated
well we would love to have you come back
kim
and to talk about how those
international treaties
impact today's plant exploration
i want to again thank you for an
absolutely fascinating start
to our series uh and we are just
so grateful to you for sharing all of
this with us
if you could stay on for a few minutes
uh those who would like to
continue chatting with you will have the
opportunity
to do that great that's
i i'd be happy to do that thank you
and uh for everyone else we will
see you next week
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web
at cornell.edu